all right so superlatives time on this
Friday edition - PFT live Chris wide
open anything you want to talk about
where you want to hand out an award to
someone some person some team anything
go well I mean I you know I don't know
I'm just seeing this now I mean I was up
to 1:00 in the morning I didn't read the
rundown of the show so like I'm not
exactly Johnny creative here okay so
yeah I'm opening up the curtains here on
this one but I'm going with how about
Saxon ville 2.0 what I mean Jacksonville
quietly got two ballers in the draft and
we haven't talked about them yet but I
mean they kind of got a Jalen Ramsey
replacement with CJ Henderson I mean
this CJ Henderson is a really talented
player I thought he means the number one
corner on my draft board Mike I thought
he was better than a CUDA and then to
get K LaVon chasin a little later in the
round and men now you got Josh Allen and
Caleb on chasin coming off the edge and
who knows what happens with Yannick and
Gok way I don't even want to go there
but you know they're building kind of
like they did the first time around with
some freaks on the defensive side of the
ball that are just gonna be able to
overwhelm you with their physical
ability so I think that deserves a
little credit for sure
yeah and within Gok way you know I I
think I will go there I think they're
gonna tell and play for us or play for
no one in 20 Bonnie unless they unless
they get an offer that they you know
they they weren't gonna trade Jalen
Ramsay until they got blown out of the
water by the Rams to to first-round
picks in a fourth-round pick can't say
no to that now obviously don't take less
than that to get in Cocke way but
they're gonna hold firm it didn't happen
during round one last night it's not
expected to happen this weekend and it
may be that in Gok way just has to find
a way to reset his mindset and accept
that he's going to be a Jaguar for one
more year but for a team you know we're
trying to figure out are they rebuilding
are they retooling what are they doing
last night's pics instantly make them
better on the defensive side of the ball
and there was something to that whole -
etana by Louis stuff with the Jaguars
even though they never had a chance to
take him but Gardner Minshew clearly the
guy for now and they're gonna give him a
chance to see what he can do alright for
me it's the we didn't take the
Gee's award the Cincinnati Bengals I
gotta give him credit for holding firm
now I don't know what they were offered
if anything specifically by the Dolphins
but they didn't waver in their
conviction the Joe borough was their guy
you know we addressed this yesterday I
wrote about it at PFT there are only a
handful of guys in the NFL who are
untouchable from a trade standpoint and
basically what they were faced with was
an opportunity to trade Joe borough
before we ever took a snap in the NFL
they didn't do it they wouldn't do it
and I think they recognize what he means
to that region to that team to that city
to that stadium from the standpoint of
filling it up once we get to the point
where stadiums are allowed to be filled
up again and this is the kind of this is
the kind of transformative player that
they hoped they were getting with Carson
Palmer Palmer never really embraced it
he was a California guy not an Ohio guy
now they got an Ohio guy and it just
feels different already
that borough is gonna take to Cincinnati
whatever hesitation may have been there
and and it may not go as smoothly from a
contractual standpoint now or three
years from now between burrow and the
Bengals but I just think from a fit
standpoint it makes sense and it really
helps elevate a team that maybe now can
move toward contending in the AFC North
yeah Mike agreed I mean it's just it's a
no-brainer
you know you know like I said it was the
cleanest film I've ever watched for a
quarterback coming out in the draft and
it's not just like it was like oh yeah I
know there was talent around him but it
wasn't like he was just throwing the
wide open people and had a perfect
pocket to throw the ball in all the time
I mean it's everything about this guy
it's the first guy I've evaluated that I
went wow this guy reminds me of Peyton
Manning I mean he really does he's got
that kind of charisma and personality
about him and he just I think he
embraces the pressure of being the
number-one pick being the guy he loves
it it's got a great story got a great
upbringing
he's great kid I mean awesome I'm with
you Mike I'm glad they didn't mess that
up and went with Joe borough all right I
mean I always like to have give a little
love to the big ugly guys so you've seen
Lord of the Rings right you shall not
pass you shall not pass a word I'm gonna
give that to the three team
that or let's go to the four teams that
took offensive tackles what do you want
to say smarty why before you try to come
off like you know anything about the
Lord of the Rings I'm gonna I'm gonna
challenge you on this where was that
line uttered who was it uh turd bye
until whom was it uh turd
it was Gandalf the gray on the
underground bridge Wendy the what the
hell was that big a Kraken or a grog in
or it just a huge freaking animal beast
all right when he stopped in and he fell
into the pit right because the thing
through the whip up and then he went
from Gandalf great again off the white
so screw you I know my movie references
all right so let me get back to football
all right but I shall not go thank you
okay you can correct me after this but I
want to give love to some of the
offensive tackles in the draft right you
know it's such an important position
we often gloss it over I hear too much
of all the man I don't want to take an
offensive lineman in the top ten I mean
we could trade down and probably get
these listen the first three tackles off
the board will you know Thomas from
Georgia wills from Bama Makai Becton
they have like big-time
borderline Hall of Fame type Talent in
my opinion these were franchise left
tackle type players and if you're the
Giants and you want Daniel Jones and
sake want Barkley to work out and be
good you need somebody to block for him
so that was a great pick by them you
know there's there's no downside to him
Jedrek wills for the Cleveland Browns
you want Baker Mayfield the Nick Chubb
and Odell Beckham jr. to catch the ball
they need some time to throw and open up
some holes of the run game and then the
same thing with the Jets
Le'Veon Bell Sam darn old you know Makai
Becton is a freak of a human being so
you know I think that's gotten glossed
over let alone I know Tristan worse went
to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers but I don't
think he's the class of those first
three guys but we just got to get over
that narrative it's too important of a
position there's too many free key
players at defensive end in the NFL and
you need freaks on your offensive line
on the edge to block those type of guys
yeah and it was by the way the bridge of
cause of Dune in the mines of moria
as Gandalf was trying to leave the crew
out it was the Balrog it was the battle
about drums in the deep and the Balrog
emerged and yes Gandalf the Grey became
Gandalf the white I'm very impressed
that you knew enough you get about 60%
credit for that one so that way the
light next one for me I can go a lot of
different directions here this is the
early head scratch of the night award
and this goes to something that you and
I have been talking about for a while
the lions trade darius slay stay put at
number three after making it abundantly
clear to anyone who was paying attention
that they wanted to trade down they were
desperate to trade down they ultimately
were not able to trade down they'd take
a corner back in Jeff Okuda to replace
the guy that they traded away does that
really make the Lions any better does
that make Bob Quinn the GM I'm at
Patricia the head coach and he's safer
in their jobs Chris well I do think it
does you know Okuda is the most game
ready ready to go well polished well
schooled really well taught DB in the
draft he's technically sound he played a
lot of different defenses at Ohio State
he's really good in all those areas and
he's a really good football player and
they needed somebody that they could
depend on day one to come in and play
and be able to understand all the things
that Matt Patricia does do on defense
even though it's a lot of man-to-man
there's a lot of nuance to it too and I
think from that aspect they needed to go
with somebody that they really just I
think they trusted and they felt like
they could go get on the field
immediately and have no issues you know
Henderson and Terrell to me as the
cornerback position are more talented
they have more physical ability and
explosiveness and Ross speed and
explosion and all those types of things
but I understand this is a these are
guys that you know they might not want
to wait on those guys to kind of find
their footing by week six or seven and
because they're they're a little more
raw that way so I get the the logic here
and Mike the big thing is with the trade
down who was anybody looking to trade up
for in the top ten that was my big thing
all along that's why I didn't think
there would be
a lot of trades in the top ten because I
didn't think there was the commodities
this year that we're gonna make teams
just be really a oh man I got to get up
there and get these guys or we're gonna
run out or not gonna have this available
later on in the draft so I understand it
and there was a lot of noise yesterday
and I think the Dolphins played this to
perfection with their - etana by Louis
situation because we really didn't know
what they were going to do there was
talk that they wanted to get to number
three to get a tackle before the Giants
could write so nobody was really
thinking that nobody I didn't know what
the Dolphins were gonna do when they
were on the clock that is the best way
to play it you keep it wide open you
keep everyone guessing and then when you
take your pick you say this is the guy
we wanted all along and it worked out
perfectly no one jumped over us to take
the guy that we wanted obviously no one
jumped over them and no one took the guy
they wanted unless for some reason they
were gonna take Andrew Thomas the fourth
overall pick that went to the Giants but
again if you keep your mouth shut no one
ever knows that you keep your mouth
completely shut and you take the guy
that you take and that's the guy that
was number one on your board and that's
your story and you're sticking to it all
right
last one for me this is the NFL jr.
award proving yet again the SEC is the
closest thing to an NFL minor-league 15
of 17 or 15 of 32 rather
players taken last night 17 weren't 15
were all from the SEC LSU had five in
all one short of the record set in 2004
by the University of Miami between LSU
and Alabama you know they they could
just be the straight pipeline to the NFL
and and just like what mike Mayock did
last year remember he was just taking
Alabama and Clemson guys can you figure
hey these guys play well at those
schools they're gonna be fine at the NFL
level just take LSU and Alabama guys
take SEC guys and you're gonna be fine
well yeah I mean SEC is it's not even
close I mean it's such the king of
college football that's where you know
you know last year we were getting close
to where I was going man maybe we should
just have three teams for the SEC and
the college football final four I know
we're trying to be fair to everybody but
you know ultimately there's a top two or
three teams in the SEC or the top two or
three teams in the country and
almost not fair because they have to
play each other and their conference is
so much more talented it has so much
more depth than any of the other
conferences it's not even close you know
it's really not and I mean you're just
you're right the SEC is so special but
between LSU Bama Clemson Ohio State you
know that to me Mike is evidence right
there of why you know you you can't have
free enterprise you need a drop because
every all these kids are going to that
stop stop stop it you went to your
bottoms in a row and you cut me your
yeah you went and you went this one
you're the guy that didn't have a plan
you're the guy that stayed up till 1:00
but didn't bother to look at the rundown
so shut up listen do I have no no you
warned you do you admitted you didn't
even look at the rundown I mess up with
two good ones I'm smart Bobby big Jeff
listen how many college programs are
there how many college programs are
there that have to fill out rosters 200
hundred right yeah you're talking about
32 NFL franchises and no one is gonna
choose to go play for a team and sit on
the bench oh hey oh I'm a quarterback I
want to play for the Chiefs all they
have Patrick my home's all still go play
for the Chiefs and sit on the bench
behind him it will all work out with a
salary cap and a structure that limits
what you can pay rookies based upon how
you finish the year before it would work
don't play that
college football card on me and oh by
the way college football is still
immensely popular even though it's only
a handful of teams that run the sport
yeah I know but it doesn't matter I mean
I disagree with you I don't care let's
get back to the draft and the players
you're the one that tried to try to take
it in a different direction all right
what do you have
I mean you Bobby big chess to me but to
superlatives in a row but to new age
warren sapp okay that's what I want to
do with my super lit because I didn't
got that Derrick that could be good that
could be good and they're gonna be bad
we're just talking about on the field
here big guy just about all right but I
do look at the Carolina Panthers pick at
number seven Derrick brown I mean it's
to me it's like this is
like you could do an experiment on like
the evolution of mankind this is more in
SAP twenty-five years later I mean this
really is or 26 years later whatever it
is you know he just he's gotten bigger
and stronger and faster but I mean Derek
Brown to me was a top five talent Mike
as we talked about Carolina desperately
needed that type of player and his
athleticism his ability to create havoc
his ability to hold up first double
teams I mean he is a monster of a player
and he really does he reminded me a lot
of Warren Sapp except he's probably like
25 pounds bigger than Warren Sapp at the
time so that was uh I think a much
needed area to address for the Carolina
Panthers and I think they got like a
big-time all-pro defensive tackle is
gonna be a star in the NFL for a long
time and they need that they need a
cornerstone player on the defensive side
of the ball now that Luke Kuechly is
retired Julius Peppers has been gone for
a while they need a guy who's going to
develop into the heart and soul of their
defense under Matt rule and under the
ownership of David town
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports